That day on the beach it changed you, you want revenge
What you think?
You're going to jump from cell to cell taking out terrorists? For starters,  yeah.
Our people here like your agenda, Mitch. I know exactly what to do with you.
So what do I need to know about this guy? He's a warrior one of the best I've ever known.
Some bad shit happened to you now you want to go kill terrorists, am I right? Out there it's about the mission - not about you.
Slice a man's throat right here like this.
He's testing through the roof. Speed, focus. He's off the charts. I've seen off the charts before. Not like this.
You think you're special? Never, ever let it get personal.
What is it you think we do here? Kill people who need to be killed.
We got a problem. Six days ago 15 kilos of plutonium went missing.
Hey look at this. It can't be him. It's him Irene, it's Ghost.
Why's this guy after you? Something personal Sir?
Everything he did there, I taught him how to do it.
There is a fucking nuke in play. You have 48 hours, to stop him.
I trusted you. You should have come for me.
Eliminate the Target. Yes, sir
Where's the rest of your team? Where's the new me?
This whole thing is just a means to an end for you isn't it?
No, this is just the beginning.
you